non
une ville refuge pour les ukrainiens
déplacés
vive et accueillante
mais plus difficilement faire oublier
l'exil
olexi 19 ans s'est réfugiée ici avec ses
proches dans cet endroit qu'il connaît à
peine le jour il a quitté sa maison dire
pillé nos banlieues kiev restera à
jamais gravé dans sa mémoire
sa grand mère et lui ont fui en
catastrophe dans la voiture d'un ami
pour échapper aux bombes cyrus qui
s'abattaient sur la ville sur la route
ils ont découvert l'horreur les
carcasses de quatre voitures calcinées
des familles qui les précédait de
quelques kilomètres bombardé
des gens qui tentaient comme nous de
fuir une ville à moitié détruite
il y avait des bombes il avait peur il
voulait se sauver mais la terreur ne
s'arrête pas là
une roue de leur véhicule a été touché
par un projectile
effrayés ils ont roulé un pneu à plat
sans s'arrêter jusqu'à un endroit
sécuritaire
je voulais seulement rester en vie dit
il quand il parle des russes olexi un
peu de mots
ils devraient tous payés même s'il est
maintenant en sécurité les mauvaises
nouvelles continuent d'arriver
il y a quelques jours il a reçu des
photos de la maison familiale
complètement détruite dans un
bombardement mais son père et lui ont
bien l'intention de retourner à irbine
pour rebâtir leurs foyers et leurs
quartiers
nous voulons aider les gens à retourner
y vivre
en projet un espoir auquel s'accrocher
un patient comme tordu craignait de
ventre et à la maison ici louis blouin
radio canada ils vivent